I'm happy because I've worked really
hard in school and now it's summer
vacation and I can enjoy what I've done
so far my name is Martin and I live in
Miller Park in California in the United
States
I have a few Records and I listen to
those records and it's really nice to
listen to the older music from the 60s
and 70s and I'll cease my radio to
listen to their newest hits of this day
I like science because it helps people
get better understanding of the world
and it just helps people out if you
eventually make your own discoveries
my dad he grew up basically in the
ghettos of Serbia and now he's here as a
designer
my mom is some pizza and my dad is
Bronco and I really loved them so much
and they mean everything to me my
parents actually moved here to America
from Europe and then they become they
became successful or at least I think so
well I think that the big problem in the
world that we have right now is that
we're not really replenishing our
environment as fast as we are consuming
everything and we should focus on
getting power from the Sun because
there's so much sunlight coming from the
Sun and if we all had solar panels on
our roofs we would have so much energy
that electric cars are things that need
a lot of energy would be really easy to
have